nintendo's latest direct was a wild ride
and we're talking all about that and
more
nintendo aired its first direct of 2022
and made a handful of fun announcements
for fans one of the biggest
announcements came in the form of a
booster course pack for mario kart 8
deluxe that will add 48 additional dlc
courses to the popular racing game by
the end of 2023 the first wave of
courses arrives on march 18th the dlc
will include remastered courses from
earlier games a-courses will be released
across six waves for a total of 48
courses in all some of the courses
confirmed so far include coconut mall
from mario kart wii cocoa mountain from
mario kart 64 and tokyo blur from mario
kart tour these will be available in the
first wave and they can be played
locally and online the booster course
pack costs 25 on its own but it's also
included in the nintendo switch online
plus expansion pass at no extra cost
along with that nintendo is finally
delivering us the sequel to one of the
wii's best games like his predecessor
switch sports delivers a bunch of
different sports to play all of which
are played with motion controls other
highlights from the direct include new
difficulty modes for metroid prime dread
a new co-op trailer for splatoon 3
earthbound and earthbound beginnings
coming to switch online as well as a
brand new mario strikers game nintendo
closed the show with the reveal of
xenoblade chronicles 3 a new trailer for
the upcoming jrpg showcase the game's
characters and tease the plot xenoblade
chronicles 3 is scheduled for launch in
september of 2022
according to multiple new reports a new
assassin's creed game focused on stealth
is coming either this year or next year
and will feature the assassin's creed
valhalla character basm bloomberg was
the first to report on the supposed
existence of this game which is
supposedly codenamed rift eurogamer's
own sources said that this is a real
project as well according to bloomberg's
report ubisoft originally conceived this
rumored project as an expansion for
valhalla however it's now allegedly
being prepared for release as a
standalone game rift or whatever the
game will end up being called if it's
the real deal will not feature the type
of gigantic open worlds that the
franchise is known for instead it will
be smaller in scope and focus on stealth
gameplay instead of the action rpg
nature of origins through valhalla this
possible project is separate from
ubisoft's ambitious new project
assassin's creed infinity which is
confirmed to be in development but still
doesn't have any concrete information
yet
a spokesperson for ubisoft sent a
statement to gamespot that said in part
quote we don't comment or engage on
rumors or speculation as they do a
disservice to our development teams and
community
sony has rolled out a new beta for its
ps4 and ps5 adding a suite of ui changes
adjustments and accessibility features
most notably though is an entirely new
feature coming to ps5 that will let
users give the console voice commands
limited to us and uk users players who
make it into the beta will be able to
have their ps5 open on a game or an app
as well as pause or resume media
playback using their voice just like ps4
users can the ps5's ui is also getting
some slight changes although folders a
popular feature on the ps4
aren't on that list instead users will
be able to filter their game collection
by genre and tag some to be kept on
their home screen additionally the home
screen will be able to hold a total of
14 games and apps according to the blog
post access will only be open to
selected beta participants in applicable
countries of course everyone with a ps5
or ps4 will be able to try out these new
features when they officially roll out
later this year assuming that they do so
what was your favorite part of the
nintendo direct let us know in the
comments below
you